kurzer lockdown für alle
die bundesregierung fordert erneut
schärfere maßnahmen der weitere kurs in
der korona politik bleibt aber unklar
trotz möglicher nebenwirkungen die eu
empfiehlt den impfstoff von astrazeneca
weiter ohne einschränkungen
gut gespielt und doch verloren borussia
dortmund hofft weiter auf den einzug ins
halbfinale der champions league
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
heute 19 uhr mit von der partie diese
woche norbert lehmann für den sport ein
stück von mir
was ist nun aus dem vorschlag von cdu
chef laschet geworden der dritten corona
welle mit einem kurzen aber harten
lockdown vorzubeugen
kanzlerin und bayerns ministerpräsident
müller sind dafür wenn die länder nicht
entschieden genug gegen die pandemie
ankämpften hieß es aus berlin und
münchen müsse die verabredete notbremse
bundeseinheitlich gezogen werden
andere länder chefs und chefinnen sehen
das jedoch anders
klaus brodbeck es gibt auch im auto
nicht einmal aussteigen müssen sie hier
in schwelm in nrw wieder ein impfzentrum
wieder armin laschet und wieder versucht
er die idee vom brücken lockdown zu
verteidigen
es liegt jetzt ein vorschlag auf dem
tisch und ich bitte einfach die anderen
was sind denn eure ideen
wir haben alle mit der bundeskanzlerin
verabredet es soll noch einmal etwas
passieren
die bundeskanzlerin selbst hat das
deutlich gemacht innerhalb von zwei
wochen müssen ideen auf den tisch
tatsächlich sind ideen seit märz auf dem
tisch nur bisher beinahe jedes
bundesland die notbremse anders
interpretiert die aussicht auf mehr
gemeinsamkeit dass die kanzlerin heute
ausdrücklich begrüßen die
intensivmediziner sind beunruhigt und
warnen deswegen ist auch jede forderung
nach einem kurzen einheitlichen lockdown
richtig bayern verschiebt geplante
erleichterungen um zwei wochen und will
mehr testen
auch die grünen sind für harte maßnahmen
am besten bundesweit
es bleibt sehr gefährlich und deswegen
muss die marsch rede sein
vorsicht mit vernunft vorsicht mit
vernunft bleibt jetzt die generelle
linie
wir brauchen keinen hin und her mehr wir
brauchen jetzt einen radikalen
wellenbrecher mit konzept mit klarheit
mit einigkeit und zwar gerne bundesweit
und am besten im bundestag und im
bundesrat beschlossen so dass bund und
länder beieinander
hoch im norden hingegen soll im rahmen
der bestehenden regeln gelockert werden
wo niedrige instanzen das zu lassen bloß
weil in bayern die werte dramatisch hoch
zum teil sind muss es ja nicht richtig
sein im kreis nordfriesland mit einer
inzidenz von 15
genau die gleichen maßnahmen dort auch
zu ergreifen tag zwei nachlasses idee
mit dem brücken lockdown selbst eigene
leute folgen ihm nicht grundlage für die
krone entscheidungen ist unter anderem
die zahl der neuinfektionen das problem
die aktuellen daten haben keine große
aussagekraft weil während der feiertage
weniger getestet und gemeldet wurde
das robert-koch-institut zählten 9677
neue fälle innerhalb von 24 stunden
deutlich weniger als vor einer woche
298 weitere menschen sind an oder mit
cupid 19 gestorben
die sieben tage incidents liegt bei
110,1 das mittel gegen die pandemie ist
impfen und deshalb wurde die
einschätzung der europäischen
arzneimittelbehörde ema mit spannung
erwartet wie weiter mit astrazeneca
jetzt die empfehlung der impfstoff könne
weiter ohne einschränkung eingesetzt
werden
der nutzen würde die risiken überwiegen
ja da fragen wir noch mal bei anne
gellinek in brüssel nach anne also eine
empfehlung für astrazeneca trotz
möglicher nebenwirkungen
ist das nun eine freigabe zweiter klasse
nein das würde ich nicht sagen die ema
ist sich treu geblieben
sie hat ihre meinung eigentlich seit
beginn der zweifel an astrazeneca nicht
verändert und den impfstoff immer
uneingeschränkt empfohlen
allerdings hat sie heute auch zugegeben
dass sie einen zusammenhang zwischen
astrazeneca impfungen und sehr selten
auftretenden hirn venenthrombosen sieht
aber so die iaea das risiko an einer
kurve 19 infektion zu sterben sei immer
noch um ein vielfaches höher als an
einer seltenen nebenwirkung damit
überlässt die ema im grunde den
eu-mitgliedsstaaten wie sie weiter mit
dem impfstoff verfahren und hier gibt es
ein ziemlich unterschiedliches bild mehr
als ein dutzend mitgliedstaaten darunter
deutschland für impfen als freisinniger
nur noch an ältere menschen über 55 oder
über 60 und noch ist nicht klar wie man
darauf reagiert es gibt noch keine
reaktion auf band aus berlin ob sich an
dieser praxis etwas ändert ein schwenk
vollzogen allerdings hat großbritannien
dass er bisher immer mit großer
überzeugung hinter dem impfstoff von
astrazeneca der ja in großbritannien
entwickelt wurde stand die briten haben
heute angekündigt dass sie ganz junge
menschen unter 30 möglichst nicht mehr
mit astrazeneca impfen wollen
denn bei ihnen sei das risiko an einer
corona infektion zu sterben eben sehr
gering und das einer thrombose damit zu
hoch vielen dank für die umfangreiche
erklärung anne gellinek in brüssel in
deutschland stehen also alle irg
wirkstoffe weiter zur verfügung und so
soll es jetzt auch mit dem impf tempo
besser werden
allein bei montech will im vergleich zu
ende märz seine wöchentliche liefermenge
in diesem monat mehr als verdoppeln
aber auch die übrigen hersteller haben
mehr angepeilt und so soll deutschland
im april fast genau so viel impfstoff
erhalten wie im gesamten ersten quartal
dieses jahres dann könnte auch bald bei
den hausärzten mehr ankommen
volker dutschek dr abdul mateen arbeitet
durch keine mittagspause
der stuttgarter allgemeinmediziner impft
seit heute bei antec die patientin hat
er sich gezielt aus der kartei gesucht
ältere menschen ab 80 mit
vorerkrankungen an
und herz die resonanz war groß natürlich
die haben mit der große wille und mit
großem interesse unserer anrufe
entgegengenommen und ihr interesse
gemeldet rgf zu werden
astrazeneca und nebenwirkungen viele
menschen haben bei dem thema
grundsätzlich bedenken auch wenn die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde heute
erneut grünes licht für den impfstoff
gibt viele unter 60 die die erstimpfung
mit astrazeneca hinter sich haben fragen
sich was ist eigentlich mit meiner
zweitimpfung eine zweitimpfung würde
würde sich dann an impfstoff von baxter
oder von moderner anbieten
die beruhen auch auf einem ähnlichen
prinzip dass sie nämlich immunreaktionen
gegen das bike protein des corona virus
auslösen
und deshalb kann man mit diesen zwei
impfungen dann auch die immunreaktionen
die durch astrazeneca zunächst in gang
gebracht wurde verstärken und länger
anhaltend machen
anderenorts wie hier in wismar gibt es
lange schlangen wenn astrazeneca zum
impfen angeboten wird das landratsamt
hat ostermontag alle menschen über 60
zum impfen eingeladen weil die
astrazeneca dosen im regal liegen
blieben viele wollen sich impfen lassen
weil sie angst vor langzeitfolgen nach
einer infizierung haben die immunität
ist für viele das hauptziel
denn der kleine pieks bedeutet mehr
lebensqualität und sicherer
gerade dann wenn auch der partner
geimpft ist impfen und was dann welche
freiheiten geimpfte zurück bekommen
sollten können sie diskutieren unter
anderem mit einem mitglied des
ethikrates in zdf heute live um 19 30 in
unserem youtube kanal und auf zdf heute
online plattform annalena baerbock oder
robert habeck wer soll die grünen in die
bundestagswahl führen
am 19 april wollen die grünen mitteilen
wer die kanzlerkandidatur übernimmt
endgültig wird das dann auf einem
parteitag im juni entschieden
es ist das erste mal dass die grünen mit
einer kanzlerkandidatin bzw mit einem
kanzlerkandidaten in eine bundestagswahl
gehen
die korona krise kommt die öffentlichen
haushalte teuer wie sehr lässt das
gesamtdefizit aus dem vergangenen jahr
ahnen dass jetzt feststeht
unterm strich ergibt sich ein minus von
189,2 milliarden euro das größte defizit
seit der wiedervereinigung dabei sanken
einerseits die einnahmen durch steuern
um 3,5 gleichzeitig stiegen die ausgaben
um 12,1 prozent
allein die korona hilfen und mittel für
den gesundheitsfonds
bei 30,8 milliarden euro in vielen
ländern leidet die wirtschaft unter der
pandemie erstaunlich gut aber ist polen
durch die krise gekommen während in der
eu das bruttoinlandsprodukt im vierten
quartal insgesamt um 4,6 prozent
eingebrochen ist kam deutschland mit
einem minus von 3,6 etwas besser davon
polen liegt nur bei minus 2,7 prozent
das land wurde zwar von corona hart
gebeutelt hat aber aktuell die
niedrigste arbeitslosenquote in der eu
natalie steger erklärt warum gleich
sechs fabriken betreibt dieses
tochterunternehmen der deutschen bosch
gruppe in polen polens stärke
die produktion von gebrauchsgütern ein
grund für den erfolg der wirtschaft im
land das geld das die kunden früher zum
beispiel für reisen ausgegeben haben
geben sie jetzt für haushaltsgeräte aus
wie beispielsweise für spülmaschinen
die firma produziert nicht nur hier
sondern bietet von polen aus fürs
unternehmen auch den weltweiten it
service an polen als standort ist längst
mehr als die verlängerte werkbank
deutschlands mit innovationskraft und
stark im export bohlen gehört
beispielsweise zu den weltmarktführern
bei der herstellung bei der entwicklung
von computerspielen auch danach ist die
nachfrage gestiegen
polen kommt im eu vergleich recht gut
durch die krise die wirtschaft basiert
weniger auf tourismus und dienstleister
was beides von corona schwer getroffen
ist sondern auf industrieproduktion die
nationalkonservative regierung schüttet
außerdem hohe rettungsgelder aus und
reibt sich den wirtschaftlichen erfolg
auf die fahnen
allerdings strukturreformen nach der
wende und der eu beitritt haben den weg
geebnet
die erfolgsfaktoren die den jetzigen
zustand der polnischen wirtschaft
begünstigt haben sind jahrelang
gewachsen das ist nicht das produkt der
einen oder der anderen regierung eine
große herausforderung bleibt die
energiewende weg von der kohle und der
permanente zwist mit brüssel in sachen
rechtsstaatlichkeit denn ein
vertrauensverlust kann der wirtschaft
mittelfristig durchaus schaden
corona ist auch eine krise der
menschenrechte zu diesem fazit kommt
amnesty international im jahresbericht
für 2020 in vielen teilen der welt
hätten sich ungleichheit und
unterdrückung verstärkt repressive
regierungen nähmen die gesundheitskrise
als vorwand um noch autoritärer
vorzugehen
auch hätten häusliche und
geschlechtsspezifische gewalt zugenommen
amnesty hat auch die haftbedingungen des
kremlkritikers alexei navalny kritisiert
sie kämen der folter gleich und das mit
möglicherweise lebensbedrohlichen folgen
in ballnähe ist inzwischen im
hungerstreik 2020 hatte er einen
giftanschlag in russland überlebt und
war in berlin behandelt worden
nach seiner rückkehr wurde er zu
zweieinhalb jahren straflager verurteilt
christian senn berichtet eigentlich
waren anastassia wassiljewa hausärztin
von alexei navalny und weitere mediziner
gestern zum straflager in packhof
gekommen um sich selbst ein bild zu
machen von der wahlen ist
gesundheitszustand doch man ließ sie
erst gar nicht rein
heute schafften es nach eines anwälte
ihn zu besuchen nach etlichen anläufen
er hat weiterhin schmerzen im rücken und
in einem bein und er verliert das gefühl
in den beinen und auch in den häf'n
zwei bandscheibenvorfälle seien
festgestellt worden heißt es alexej
nawalny hier im schwarzen haft anzug
aufgenommen von einer überwachungskamera
vor zwölf tagen
seit ende märz ist russlands
bekanntester häftling im hungerstreik um
medizinische hilfe zu erzwingen
jetzt kamen auch noch fieber und husten
dazu bei drei mithäftlingen wurde
tuberkulose festgestellt sagt navalny
scharfe kritik kommt heute von amnesty
international russland bringen aber
möglicherweise in die situation eines
langsamen todes die tatsache dass er
alle ein bis zwei stunden geweckt wird
ist eine form von folter dass er keinen
zugang zu einem arzt hat dem er vertraut
ist eine form von misshandlung aus dem
kreml hieß es knapp navalny habe kein
anrecht auf eine sonderbehandlung für
die ärztin war ziele war ihre begleiter
und auch journalisten endete der
gestrige straflager besuch übrigens mit
einer festnahme
der vorwurf verletzung der regeln für
öffentliche veranstaltungen fast fünf
jahre ist der putschversuch in der
türkei her
heute gab es urteile gegen mutmaßlich
beteiligte des umsturzversuchs ein
gericht in ankara sprach unter anderem
38 frühere militärs schuldig sie müssen
lebenslang ins gefängnis
die urteile sind teil eines mammut
verfahrens gegen fast 500 angeklagte bei
dem gescheiterten putsch gegen präsident
erdogan im juli 2016 waren mehr als 250
menschen getötet worden
zehntausende wurden seitdem verhaftet
jetzt dein blick auf die korona lage in
indien also dem land das weltweit mit am
meisten impfstoff produziert in dem aber
gleichzeitig das virus gerade grassiert
wie nie in gut einem monat hat sich die
zahl der täglichen neuansteckungen fast
verzehnfacht auch weil die regierung
beim impfen der eigenen bevölkerung kaum
vorankommt und stattdessen etwa die
hälfte der dosen exportiert ohne
lockdown geht es nicht mehr hat nun die
indische hauptstadt neu delhi
entschieden normen odenthal
nehmt alle zur kenntnis dass die
stadtverwaltung eine nächtliche
ausgangssperre verhängt zwischen 22 und
5 uhr früh
wenn wir dann noch einen geöffneten
laden erwischen drohen harte strafen
es kommt mal wieder unangekündigt
plötzlich und mit sofortiger wirkung
genau wie beim großen lockdown vor einem
jahr werden die menschen in neu delhi
überrumpelt ich fahre immer die taxi
spätschicht zwei euro habe ich seit dem
nachmittag verdient und jetzt wovon soll
ich meine familie ernähren wenn abends
keiner mehr kommt und kaufte trifft mich
das hart aber die ausgangssperre muss
wohl sein weil corona sich so verbreitet
115.000 neue fälle allein heute die
metropole mumbai steckt regelmäßig im
lockdown delhi zieht nun mit
ausgangssperren nach die impfkampagne
hakt 87 millionen dosen sind gespritzt
das klingt viel aber indien hat 1,3
milliarden einwohner
der vormarsch des virus ist kaum zu
bremsen wie konnte es so rasant so weit
kommen
wir können nicht neue mutationen für
alles verantwortlich machen es ist unser
leichtsinniges nachlässiges verhalten
das uns in diese krise führt das muss
das ganze land verstehen und sich
endlich an die regeln halten
das fällt schwer gerade jetzt die
container wird gefeiert die größte
religiöse party der welt massen strömen
an den ganges das bad im heiligen fluss
reinigt die seele dass es auch vor
corona schützt während verlassen und mit
motorschaden treibt ein 110 meter langes
frachtschiff weiter auf see vor der
westküste von norwegen
das für heute geplante abschleppen wurde
wegen des schlechten wetters verschoben
die besatzung war bereits am montag per
hubschrauber gerettet worden
das schiff hat schlagseite nachdem bei
schwerer see die ladung verrutscht war
an bord sind auch 350 tonnen schweröl
ja und jetzt zum sport und zum
viertelfinale der
fußball-champions-league tja und da hat
bayern münchen heute abend ein schweres
spiel vor sich gegen paris st germain
und dortmund hat einst hinter sich gegen
manchester city
der bvb verlor gestern abend zwar mit 1
2 zeigte aber eine starke leistung wie
mut macht für das rückspiel in einer
woche
noch ist es nicht vorbei für dortmund
und rené winter sind respektvoll das gut
bei der kontrahenten nach dem hinspiel
dem bvb gelingt durch reus das so
wichtige auswärtstor
der zwischenzeitliche ausgleich in der
84 favorit city mit dem führungstreffer
in der 19 minute war es auf die bräune
danach aber der bvb im pech diese aktion
zum tor von bellingham abgepfiffen und
nachdem bereits gesehenen ausgleich von
reus in der 90 minute sogar noch der
siegtreffer für city gündogan aufschoben
das brutal ärgerlich dass wir verschluss
von so einem gegentor kriegen haben ja
eine super ausgangssituation gewesen ist
es trotzdem die niederlage zwar unnötig
die chance aufs weiterkommen aber weiter
intakt aus kreuz gelegt wurde der
deutsche basketball nationalspieler
dennis schröder
trotzdem gab es einen 110 zu 101 sieg
seiner los angeles lakers gegen die
toronto raptors das spektakuläre foul
hatte zwei platzverweise zur folge es
ist noch früh im spiel als schröder für
die lakers in weiß oder an obi aus
toronto foult der revanchiert sich und
legt schröder um dann handgemenge als
logische folge der ungewöhnlichen ringer
einlagen die in den usa beim wrestling
beliebt ist die schiedsrichter sind hier
praktischerweise auch ihre eigenen video
assistenten sie schickten die
auffälligsten streithähne an obi und
herren vom feld schröder bleibt drauf
macht zwölf punkte und ist auf play off
kurs mit den lakers die weiterhin auf
ihren verletzten superstar lebron james
verzichten müssen
ja und jetzt geht es hoch hinaus ein
atemberaubender snowboard weltrekord
aufgestellt von einem 16-jährigen in der
größten halfpipe der welt im
schweizerischen laax springt valentino
rossi die 730 über den rand hinaus der
teenager aus australien verbessert damit
die alte bestmarke von
snowboard legende shaun white aus den
usa um 30 cm
beeindruckend auch die lotto zahlen
beeindrucken das hängt natürlich davon
ab ob und was sie getippt haben wir sind
die gewinnzahlen 9 10 18 19 36 37 und
die superzahl 0
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und dem zdf text auf
seite 55 7
morgen wird es etwas milder und die
schneeschauer ziehen ostwärts ab ob der
frühling einen neuen anlauf wagt das
erfahren sie gleich von katja schäfer
das war es von uns danke für ihr
interesse klaus kleber und das heute
journal um 314 und uns gibt's morgen
abend wieder um 7 bis dahin machen sie
es gut
egal wie das wetter wird zu hause will
man sich wohlfühlen deshalb nutzt frosch
auch wirkstoffe aus europäischem anbau
beispielsweise aus raps oder oliven die
kraftvoll beim reinigen helfen frosch
für ein zuhause zum wohlfühlen
[Musik]
übrigens viele frosch wirkstoffe kommen
direkt aus deutschland ohne lange
transportwege frosch für aktiven
klimaschutz
[Musik]
entdecken sie das neue wohlgefühl dies
bei marina das jetzt versandkostenfrei
bestellen zahlen begleiten unser leben
unsere leidenschaft sind die zahlen der
finanzwelt deshalb arbeiten wir täglich
daran mit investmentfonds mehr aus ihrem
geld zu machen
ganz unabhängig von der wetterlage union
investment aus geld zukunft machen
deutschlands meistgekaufte matratze
jetzt bestellen auf bett1 de
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren vielleicht
haben sie in den vergangenen 24 stunden
auch so einen flockenwirbel erlebt da
kam nochmal richtig kalte luft heran und
so gab es häufig schneefälle vor allen
dingen hier in der mitte deutschlands
und auch im süden im norden war zum teil
auch regen dabei
das war richtig eiskalte luft die
inzwischen ganz kontinentaleuropa
geflutet hat und so liegen morgen die
höchsttemperaturen zwischen dem
schwarzen meer und irland nur so bei
zehn grad und nördlich von moskau ist es
mit fünf grad ebenso kümmern wie
nördlich des alpenlandes jetzt in der
nacht gibt's bei uns meist frost die
temperaturen sinken auf minus ein bis
minus 4 grad und nur in norddeutschland
bleibt es so gerade eben frostfrei und
auch heute nacht fällt noch schnee vor
allen dingen in der südhälfte und morgen
verziehen sich die schneewolken langsam
ostwärts am längsten schneit es noch in
sachsen und auch in niederbayern an den
küsten von nord- und ostsee
aber auch zwischen reifen und dem
alpenrand scheint die sonne richtig
schön bei westwind morgen bleibt es noch
kann
die höchsttemperaturen liegen zwischen 2
grad im westerzgebirge und elf grad am
oberrhein
aber schon am freitag erwarten und 7 bis
19 grad am samstag schüttelt es in
westdeutschland und am sonntag gibt es
eine wetter zweiteilung schön ab noch